this channel is not just about becoming
stronger it's about becoming stronger
smarter faster and more cunning it's
about being ready for anything in my
video on zombie apocalypse training I
said that Jason Bourne would probably be
the best person to have on your side in
that scenario Jason Bourne may not be
real but the character is nevertheless
based on real-life operatives who've
been through incredibly awesome training
in order to develop skills and abilities
that are almost superhuman these involve
many soft skills such as the ability to
manipulate to blend in and to quickly
identify a threat and to respond to it
in an appropriate manner for most of us
these are the kinds of skills that are
more likely to be useful more at the
time zombie apocalypse is a rare but we
often need to be suave and cool in
business or social settings likewise we
might one day need to respond to a
real-life crisis in order to get
ourselves and our loved ones to safety
we can certainly learn a thing or two
from the training of CIA or mi6 officers
then - here are some cool examples of
training methods they use to develop
those kinds of skills first what is the
life of an mi6 agent or CIA agent really
like disclaimer I am NOT a member of CIA
or mi6 or any other kind of secret agent
this information is based on research
I've read books and articles spoken to
friends and watched interviews on the
subject predictably then secret agents
aren't really involved in taking down
secret volcano bases or satellites with
lasers pointed at the earth in fact
their job involves relatively little
actual conflict instead they're tasked
with identifying and coaxing informants
into providing information
willingly about the country or
organization in question they need to do
this whilst also not being identified as
intelligence officers themselves this
explains why those soft skills such as
persuasion and the ability to blend in
are so important far more so than
learning parkour or hand-to-hand combat
even though that might be cooler
it's certainly not very cinematic yes it
is let's meet in the middle and say no
it is so how might you train someone to
go on a charm offensive in this manner
I've been reading a book called the big
breach by Richard Tomlinson which is the
true account of an ex mi6 agent in this
book
Tomlinson details several exercises that
you use to hone these types of skills my
favorite one with one called perfect
stranger so in perfect stranger the
objective is simple you dropped off on
your own at a random pub located in
Portsmouth England in this example and
task was getting the name contact
details and passport number of someone
there how you go about this is entirely
up to you but of course the challenge
lies in the fact that most people aren't
happily going to give out such personal
details freely to strangers or even know
their passport number or re carrying it
with them at the time so take a moment
maybe and think about how you might go
about doing this how would you approach
a stranger charm them enough and
convince them to give you their passport
number the solution that Tomlinson came
up with was to offer two girls the
opportunities to take a ride on his
imaginary boat the next day but he said
he'd need their passport details for the
coastguard another agent apparently used
to survey and just handed out sheets to
people who filled in their details
willingly a third agent started betting
strangers at the bar who obviously had
been drinking a little bit that every
passport number entered in a certain
number of digits he said he'd give ten
pounds if they could prove him wrong so
of course to prove him wrong they found
out their passport numbers one person
even calling home and of course he was
the real winner there I haven't actually
tried this however and of course it's
one thing to come up with an idea and
quite another to actually effectively
execute that idea most of us are
naturally inclined towards honesty and
we've struggled to lie convincingly or
even to strike up a conversation with
strangers I rather suspect that scoring
high on the psychopathy scale would
actually be an asset for a spy
just as we know it is for business
executives now there's no reason you
can't go about trying this exercise
yourself but I hazard that you'd be
better served to start with something
much smaller and easier and then build
up to that kind of thing which takes a
fair amount of balls most of us are
almost crippled by social pressure and
we find it very hard to break social
norms in etiquette but with practice and
training you can liberate yourself from
these tendencies and be okay with being
awkward being
rude being forthright and being
dishonest well I don't recommend that
you use these powers for evil there's a
great deal of benefit in letting to
overcome social pressures for things
like negotiation in business for meeting
new people etc so practice being strange
Tim Ferriss recommends lying down in a
public space and ignoring the
overwhelming sense of social pressures
to stand up
I've often suggested buying something in
a shop someone you won't visit often
obviously and then using a strange voice
or creating a fabricated backstory when
talking to the checkout assistant this
way you can just practice overcoming any
shyness or social awkwardness and become
much more brazen actually the book the
game by Neil Strauss details how many
pickup artists we use similar techniques
in order to develop the confidence to
approach members of the opposite sex
that means striking up conversation with
complete strangers even calling random
numbers or asking people for their
number with no Prelude of course those
who watch regularly will know that I
recently uploaded a video on CBT
cognitive behavioral therapy many of the
techniques I discussed there can
similarly be used to develop more
confidence and to stay calm in social
scenarios that would normally get your
heart racing another trick that
Tomlinson had to learn was to mi6 was
how to blend in more specifically he had
to learn how to check his six to make
sure he wasn't being followed but
without looking suspicious by constantly
looking behind himself and appearing
shifty to do this he would engage in a
practice called a dry cleaning to do
this you might pretend that you're
engaged in a different cover activity
they would naturally involve rocks
looking around
stopping and checking behind you a good
example is pretending that you're on a
shopping trip for instance another trick
is to plan a route specifically to
provide yourself with opportunities to
spot followers and observers a good
route home then for instance might
involve lots of looping back on yourself
or taking lifts and escalators the
connectors surveillance traps
situational awareness as a topic related
to this subject
it means constantly being aware of your
surroundings learning to identify
potential threats early on and taking
note of important aspects of your
environment such as weapons or escape
routes there's a fantastic article over
the Art of Manliness that describes this
in more detail and provides a whole
bunch of different ways you can develop
that skill an important aspect is that
you de loop which stands for observe
orient decide act and was outlined by
John Boyd an Air Force fighter pilot and
Miller
a strategist here observation is
achieved by smartly positioning yourself
in a room so to be able to observe as
much of the space as possible
that might mean choosing the corner seat
in a restaurant for instance so that no
one can sneak up behind you at this
point I'd also like to refer you to my
posts and videos on wide-angle vision
also called splatter vision here you
engage your peripheral vision in order
to take in a wider spectrum of
information or staying calmly alert
being more mindful of your surroundings
is important in general and not easy I'm
someone who has a tendency to be in my
own head dreaming up ideas and plans
rather than focusing on what's actually
going on around me to rectify this I
gain fi my attention by challenging
myself to look out for specific things
in my environment that might mean
counting the number of people I see
wearing blue for instance the orient
component of course is known what to
look for and have to orient yourself as
a result to do this try to establish a
baseline of normal behavior and things
that you expect to encounter in that
environment what is the average person
in this room or space doing from there
you can then look out for outliers
people who are acting differently or
strangely of course we must be aware
that not everyone who is acting
differently is going to be dangerous but
they may want a little extra scrutiny in
order to rule them out when inspecting
someone more closely an understanding of
body language may be useful this means
looking for clusters of behavior that
together might point to a specific
motivation the angle of someone's foot
can tell us who they're really
interested in for instance but it may
also just be a comfortable position so
I'll come back to this topic in future
because I'd like to do a whole video an
article on body language let me know if
that's something you'd like to see
memorizing important details might also
be useful again this is something I
might come back to in a future but for
now I recommend checking out my video on
Sherlock Holmes training finally the
decide and act stages are what determine
how you react to what you see at what
point do you make the decision to leave
a potentially dangerous environment and
at what point ease decide to call the
police the most important thing to have
is a plan as soon as you spot something
that might go wrong think of a way that
you could mitigate or evade that
situation another tip is to consider
that will often not act soon enough
there are countless reasons for this
explained in many different
psychological textbooks things like
social pressure and diffusion of
responsibility cause us often to stay
quiet and still until it's too late
so if in doubt at
there are many more models for
understanding and teaching situational
awareness one for instance focuses on
the use of four different states objects
frames implications and event horizons
another one is the Ensley model which
discusses three stages or steps those
being perception comprehension and
projection again the highest level of si
here is considered the ability to
project future actions of the elements
in the environment that is the ultimate
end goal of developing your greater
awareness if you want to read more about
those different models then check out
the full article over at the website the
bio near comm I'll link to it in the
description down below to practice try
situating yourself in a good vantage
spot in a cafe or on train and watching
people around you people watching is a
great exercise as well as looking out
for potential people of interest people
are acting unusually or deviating from
baseline try to guess what will happen
next
finally another aspect of mi6 or CIA
training is of course self-defense but
contrary to popular belief
Richard Tomlinson states in the big
breech that mi6 agents actually aren't
required to engage in hand-to-hand
combat or firefights very often their
job is to blend in after all
nevertheless they still receive basic
amounts of combat and survival training
mi6 collects Intel but it's the job of
other organizations to act on that Intel
and I was seen there's a similar lack of
emphasis on this kind of hand-to-hand
training the CIA what they have instead
is these special Activities Division z'
Special Operations Group which has the
disappointing acronym of sad SOG though
the name has been changed recently to
special Activities Center this
organization carries out strategic
covert operations and the members are
generally recruited from the Special
Operations Forces and Joint Special
Operations Command though some do come
from within the CIA the CIA hires these
individuals as paramilitary operations
officers and specialized skills officers
and they undergo a clandestine service
trainee program to learn their
additional skillset still there are
definitely abilities that we can learn
from across the spectrum of
organizations that could be useful in
real-life situations
Jason Hansen is one ex CIA operative who
now teaches many of these skills at spy
escape & evasion comm
in general the types of self-defense
training their preferred by these groups
seem to be focused on practical urban
and adaptive applications in other words
they teach us how to fight against a
knife in close quarters
to turn every objects into weapons in
one TV show Hansen demonstrated how he
trains nurses to fight off the tackers
using a flashlight showing how it could
be used to crack open a coconut and
therefore most likely a human skull I
made a video a while ago on how to be
more resourceful by overcoming
functional fixedness that's a little
more recommended watching for you but as
a general tip there are many innocuous
objects that you can carry that can be
used as powerful weapons in the right
circumstances even a phone can be used
for breaking out of locks and holds as
we are taught in karate system er is
similarly a style of martial art used by
the Russian KGB and counterintelligence
this teaches how to take a punch have to
get out of the line of sight of a weapon
and how to disarm opponents I has that
Wing Chun techniques could also be
useful for generating power over short
distance and for dealing with attacks
and an energy inefficient manner
allowing you to fight someone bigger and
stronger these are the focuses of any
fighting styles aimed at these kinds of
special operatives practicality
opportunity swift conflict resolution
context and fighting dirty as a personal
note though had also emphasized the
importance of the psychological aspect
of being able to stay calm and
level-headed and make the best decision
to not only ensure your survival but
also to maintain the integrity of your
mission if you've ever been mugged or
attacked you'll find you're at a massive
disadvantage because you're shocked and
scared and the attacker does this all
the time
so what can we learn from mi6 and CIA we
can learn the importance of those soft
skills of being able to stay calm and
social settings of being able to
convincingly lie or to do things that
are slightly awkward or unusual we've
learned about the importance and the
power of charisma and of body language
and of being more focused and aware
while staying calm and alert I'm gonna
go into all these topics in more detail
that one on body language should come in
handy and it can also check out a lot of
related topics which I'll link to in the
description down below anyways I hope
you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like please share it around that
helps me out immensely check out the
link down below and head over to the bio
near comm let me know in the comments
down below what you think of this kind
of training or if I've missed any cool
tips that you happen to know of I loved
getting advice and ideas from you guys
and I'm always integrating that into
these videos check me out on social
media and stay tuned for more videos on
fitness bodybuilding brain training
being productive working online all that
cool stuff I've got a video on healing
coming very soon so if that sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time
bye for now